sono ancora
[Musica]
fortissimo Mi vuoi
[Risate]
sposare
Aiuto Aiuto Aiuto Sono stata rinchiusa
nella prigione dal lupo
cattivo devo riuscire a scappare da
questa prigione la prigione del
lupo Ehi ciao Sono Anita e ho interrotto
un momento il video per darvi
un'informazione importantissima è appena
uscito il mio libro La città stregata
agli investigatori del mistero il mio
nuovissimo libro potete ora ordinarlo
cliccando nel link in descrizione è una
nuovissima avventura un nuovissimo
mistero da risolvere con tantissime
illustrazioni colorate Se non ce l'avete
ancora cliccate nel link in descrizione
per prenderlo subito mi raccomando
prendetelo
subito credo che abbia detto che vuole
mangiarmi Ma come faccio a scappare da
qua Aspetta un momento però perché ti
sei vestito così da
nonnetta
il lupo si è vestito da
nonna Scusa scusa
[Musica]
scusa non volevo prenderti in giro e in
effetti potrebbe essere che l'hai
mangiata la nonna come il Cappuccetto
rosso Eh per questo che mi hai dato il
vestito da Cappuccetto Rosso
vero credo proprio che voglia mangiarmi
ma come faccio adesso a scappare L'unico
che può salvarmi è vitale Ma dove si
Sarà cacciato lasciate un mi piace se
volete che riesco a scappare da questo
Escape Room per non essere mangiata dal
lupo cliccate mi piace qua sotto Vitale
dove sei
vitale sono chiusa in
prigione mm che buoni questi biscotti
Ciao Merlino Che cosa c'è mi vuoi dire
qualcosa Ma no tu vuoi questi E io non
te li posso dare questi sono dolci ti
fanno mare i denti non ti preoccupare me
li mangio io
però che cosa
Merlino da quella parte ti devo seguire
da quella
parte ma Merlino mi vuole dire qualcosa
mi ha chiesto di seguirlo e si è fermato
qui su questa porta devo aprire questa
porta se sembra che mi stia indicando di
aprire questa
[Musica]
porta no no no
no
male aiuto
auto Anica Cosa ti è
successo Ok Io non ho visto niente St
sicuramente sognando e tutto ok
Ciao
[Musica]
Aiuto Oh no Anita è stata imprigionata
dal lupo Ah ma come posso fare adesso
per
aiutarla ma certo posso chiamare il
nostro amico lupo lex Lui sì che mi
saprà aiutare e e riusciremo insieme a
ribellare Anita Sì allora eh Apri il
libro Gira due volte Chiudi il libro e
lui
apparirà Ciao lex tutto a posto Ciao
Vitale Ma che succede c'è un problema
Anita è stata imprigionata dal lupo
cattivo e ho bisogno del tuo aiuto per
liberarla Oh no Anita è stata
imprigionata E sì Da chi Da un lupo e un
lupo cattivo non sono sicuro che sia un
lupo mannaro ma sicuramente un lupo
cattivo Ma lo sai benissimo che ho paura
dei lupi mannari Io non ti posso aiutare
dai lex Almeno dimmi come posso fare a
liberarla alla fine ti sto chiedendo
solo un consiglio Ok allora puoi provare
questa soluzione che soluzione che
soluzione bevi la pozione per
trasformarti in un lupo mannaro e poi
potrai affrontarlo Ah la pozione che ho
creato qualche giorno fa eh Va bene
proverò così allora Grazie comunque leex
alla prossima Grazie Ti auguro un in
bocca al lupo eh eh Mac In bocca al lupo
Scusa volevo dire Buona fortuna Eh
grazie Alex Ciao ci vediamo Ciao lex
Grazie mille per il tuo aiuto Ok adesso
che so quello che devo fare Vado a
preparare la pozione così la berrò e
potrò liberare Anita dalla prigione
[Musica]
andiamo quel pipone di vitale è
scappato quindi non potrà
salvarmi
aiuto
Ehi lupo ma ma tu vuoi mangiarmi
vuoi mangiarmi come Cappuccetto
Rosso Oh no Dai ti prego Non mangiarmi
se mi fai uscire da qua Ti prometto che
ti cucinerò qualcosa di
buono ma uffa Ma perché vuoi mangiare
proprio me ah ah ah
non ho
capito
du
Uno
sì
due due
laggiù oh no oh
no
[Musica]
no uso anche Merlino in prigione Ma
perché cosa c'entra
[Musica]
lui
eh
cosa Non ho capito lupo hai detto
Merlino e poi fuori e poi cosa vuoi
dire ah Eh sì niente
ok
Tu
mangiare
due
persone ok Un
io du c'è la
[Musica]
seconda
Vitale Ma che cosa c'entra Merlino
Poverino perché R chiuso Merlino in
prigione ho capito Hai usato Merlino
come esca Ma possibile che Vitale non
faccia niente per
[Musica]
aiutarci ok adesso è pronta è perfetta è
proprio come quella che avevo fatto
l'altra volta non mi resta che berla e
potrò trasformarmi in lupo
[Musica]
mannaro Chissà se sta
funzionando
Eh mi sono spuntate le orecchie Sì sta
funzionando adesso posso andare a
salvare Anita preparati lupo avrai così
tanta paura che scapperai e ora vado ah
eccomi qua lupo mannaro adesso mi sono
trasformato e sono forte come
te
Vitale si è trasformato e adesso
libererò
[Musica]
Anita
ah
basta sono ancora
fortissimo Vale crede di essere forte ma
non è forte per
niente
[Musica]
ok Eh mi sa che non sono così fortissimo
come
pensavo aspetta aspetta aspetta Ma
possibile che non mi vedi Guardami Eh
c'ho delle delle bellissime orecchie dei
bellissimi peli e zampe sono proprio
come te Certo sono un pochettino più
bello di te però non lo capisci che
siamo uguali Siamo due lupi mannari
Guarda ho una bellissima coda anche E
dai facciamo la pace facciamo la pace
eh Ecco vedi sta
funzionando
[Musica]
eh
Ehi ciao sono l'emoji di Anita e sono
qua per dirti che è uscito il mio nuovo
libro La città
stregata puoi ordinarlo già cliccando
nel link in descrizione e trasformati
anche tu in un vero investigatore del
mistero per scoprire la verità sulla
città stregata e sulle sue misteriose
sparizioni affronta con coraggio
fantasmi lupi mannari e fenomeni
paranormali aiutandoci a raccogliere gli
indizi
per risolvere il caso chi sarà il
colpevole scopriamolo assieme sono
sicura che ti divertirai tantissimo a
leggere questo libro e ricordati anche
dell'alfabeto segreto perché
condivideremo tanti messaggi assieme non
c'è tempo da perdere presto Clicca
subito nel link in descrizione Per
ordinarlo subito eh Ce l'ai messo a
capirlo che sono come
te ma che cosa sta succedendo adesso ma
che cosa sta
succedendo cosa stai facendo la smetti
di
baciare è un lupo bar perché mi sta
andando i
bacetti Ma
che Che cosa sta facendo il lupo cattivo
sta sbaciucchi Vitale ma Ehi aspetta
stai Un po' esagerando adesso con tutte
queste affezioni Eh sì mi sono seduto Ok
Che cosa
c'è ma che cosa sta succedendo perché mi
sta baciando le mani mi sta Senti non
capisco Smettetela voi due Ehi lupo
cattivo sappi che Vitale è già fidanzato
con me Capito Oh basta ma che cosa vuoi
tu sei un lupo
mannaro No non sei un lupo
[Musica]
manaro una Lupa
Mannara è una
femmina
[Musica]
Anita è una Lupa Manara Calmati Calmati
Adesso calmati Vitale Vitale Vieni qua
vieni qua vieni qua scollati
scollati non non respingerla Ok come non
respingerla che cosa stai dicendo Beh
lei è innamorata di te e se lei è
innamorata di te farà qualsiasi cosa tu
voglia e quindi mi darà tutto quello che
voglio da mangiare no non pensare al
cibo puoi puoi chiedere al lupo cioè
alla Lupa di liberarmi Ah certo sì hai
ragione ma sei un genio Anita Certo
certo certo Adesso farò finta di essere
Anch'io innamorato così potrà liberarti
Ok ok convincila Mi raccomando Sì sì sì
allora mi sta
aspettando Speriamo che funzioni Ecco
bene Vedi Guarda io
volevo Volevo dirti ho sempre sognato di
avere una fidanzata così pelosa l'ho
proprio sempre sognato guarda sei
proprio Sei proprio bellissima Sì sì ma
ascolta Eh cara Lupa Ti volevo chiedere
un favore faresti qualcosa per
me oh sì faresti qualcosa per me Grazie
grazie grazie ti voglio tanto bene ti
voglio Ah Aiuto aiuto aiuto cho se la
scolla questa di doso adesso Ah sì sì sì
con calma con calma Vi chiedo solo uh un
piccolo favore ma non è che potresti
liberare la
mia mia carissima amica anit e Così noi
possiamo scappare insieme da fidanzati
eh Che ne pensi la Liber la liberi e poi
magari io scappo e
scappiamo Oh che bello forse l'ho
convinta a liberare
[Musica]
Anita c'è un po' di F interdentale che
dovresti passare qui magari te lo do
dopo il
[Musica]
bacetto vuole un bacetto vuole un
bacetto ok E ti do un
bacetto Non vol vol ok Un bacetto sull
ccia presto Anita spati sta funzionando
sta funzionando il nostro piano ha
funzionato sta prendo la porta della
prigione che c'è Ah ah ah ah ah ah
una
cosa Un
bacio un bacio nella guancia da parte di
Vitale
nuovamente E vabbè Vitale dagli questo
bacio nella guancia così apre la
porta Oh no l'effetto della pozione è
svanito Oh
no Speriamo che non se ne
accorga
Ho un'idea Perché non chiudi gli occhi
quando ti D il bacio nella guancia e
tieni gli occhi chiusi eh mi raccomando
Non aprirli per nessun
motivo chiudi gli
[Musica]
occhi
Aiuto
aiuto cosa ti sei fatto imprigionare è
finito l'effetto della pozione Hai visto
Mi sono ritornato normale ma adesso come
facciamo a uscire da questa prigione Eh
bella domanda Non lo so Non c'è nessuno
che ci può salvare adesso aspetta Ho un
piano eh Che ne pensi non è un'idea
geniale Sì Spero che funzioni però dai
proviamo
Proviamo Aspetta aspetta Ehi Lupa Lupa
aspetta Ho una proposta Ho una proposta
da farti Ecco vedi noi conosciamo un
lupo bellissimo c'ha un occhio celeste
un occhio color Ambra stupendo Sì sì sì
È bellissimo conosciamo un lupo
bellissimo Per te potrebbe diventare il
tuo fidanzato Sì ma come no sì non l'hai
neanche visto aspetta Magari tii
innamori È stupendo è davvero è un
nostro amico carissimo super
b super bello e super bravo però ascolta
un attimino
ascolta Se tu ci liberi noi ti facciamo
conoscere il nostro amico il lupo lex e
vedrai che ti innamorerai perché è
davvero bellissimo Ecco vedi se tu ci
liberi noi lo possiamo chiamare
è come se se non ci liberi come facciamo
ad uscire tu ci liberi Noi lo chiamiamo
e te lo facciamo conoscere eh Che ne
pensi
Eh dai devi per forza liberarci se vuoi
che ti facciamo conoscere il nostro
amico il lupo
lex Che bello Che bello Che bello Che
bello ce l'abbiamo fatto E adesso per
favore se ci puoi liberare Sì sì Apri i
lucchetti Apri i lucchetti Dai dai dai
dai Apri Adesso anche qui per favore
anche da questa parte è vi sono Liber
sono libera siamo liberi Finalmente
anch'io sono libero
[Musica]
finalmente SC Scusa hai ragione hai
ragione avevo per un attimo avevo
dimenticato Dobbiamo chiamare il nostro
amico
lex per presentartelo fartelo conoscere
possibilmente
innamorarsi Che bello Meno male abbiamo
sempre una copia del nostro libro con
noi non credo che piacerà molto aex
questo piano ma è l'unico piano per
salvarci Allora com'era giro du
volte lex abbiamo bisogno di nuovo del
tuo
aiuto Eccolo Ecco il nuo lex è lui è lui
Guardalo Guarda quanto è
[Musica]
bello Oh e te l'avevo detto te l'avevamo
detto che era un bel
figo eh C'ha ragione o
no ma ma quello è un lupo mannano Eh no
è una Lupa Mannara Ah perché mi sta
guardando così credo che si sia
innamorata di te
ah innamorata di me no no no mi dispiace
a me piace un'altra no
no Ah che
schifo Ah stai
seguendo
[Musica]
oggi distruggiamo questa prigione Tanto
siamo riusciti a scappare Non ci serve
più via distruggiamo la
[Musica]
prigione
cos'era questo
rumore Oh vai via vai
via per fortuna sono riuscito a farlo
andare via l'ho visto andare via da
qui Wow C'è mancato veramente
poco
No perché Lupa
perché no ma la stavo distruggendo
perché non mi serviva più questa
qui Tu hai messo in prigione me sì lo so
che hai messo in prigione me ma
perché Ah tu vuoi mordere me ma
perché io le orecchie qua sopra no io le
orecchie ce l'ho qua non qua
sopra Oh oh oh che c'è vio Car Ok
Ricominciamo Ok da
[Applauso]
capo tutto nuovo tutto nuovo
ok
i
peli I miei
peli Scusami ma non parlo il lupo
[Musica]
manarese
riproviamo da capo
fantastico tu o io io o te io e te io e
te era così facile io e te Ok io e te
un pomodoro un
pomodoro Eh ma che cosa vuoi
mi non mi fare male però questo è il
simbolo del pomodoro Scusami eh Ah ho
capito Ho capito che sbadato non ci
voleva così tanto e alla fine è semplice
hai detto orecchie la bocca grande Poi
il pomodoro e le orecch del pomodoro
erano quelle orecchiette e pomodoro
bocca grande perché si mangia tutto
insieme
Giusto
No ma come dai e mi hai detto le
orecchiette il pomodoro la bocca grande
per mangiare tutto insieme cosa vuoi che
capisca io non ti arrabbiare però non ti
arrabbiare non ti
arrabbiare Ho un'idea riproviamo da capo
questa volta semplice eh semplice
allora io te pomodoro No non era
pomodoro Ok basta
ok da
capo Tu
sì mordere coi denti perché mi vuoi
[Musica]
mordere tu Mordi me che nel frattempo mi
escono fuori le orecchie mi si allunga
il viso e e divento Veloso e e e mi
trasformo in lupo
[Musica]
mannaro aut Aiuto aiuto che paura Che
paura ha distrutto tutto Ascolta scusa
ho riflettuto a lungo Allora se già mi
hai fatto il segno del cuore vuol dire
che mi vuoi bene no e se mi vuoi bene
non mi vuoi fare del male tipo mordermi
se mi Mordi mi fa male quindi tu non mi
vuoi fare del male è vero Oh ma tipo non
c'è un altro metodo ind dolore per
trasformarmi perché mi devi per forza
mordere allora penso di aver capito sta
sta dicendo aspettate Lasciatemi pensare
Ormai sto diventando un traduttore
simultaneo Dunque Adesso riprovo
Lasciami pensare e che c'è una
soluzione
[Musica]
No
Ah vuoi dare dei bacetti agli spettatori
No io io B io B oh ah aiuto
[Applauso]
[Musica]
aiut mi sta facendo uscire Che bello Mi
sta
aspetta no tu mi vuoi baciare per
trasformarmi ho capito no no no
[Musica]
no
la lupa Mannara ha baciato Vitale Forse
perché vuole trasformarlo in lupo
mannaro ma io mi sono travestita da
Cappuccetto Rosso perché ho una trappola
per la lupa Mannara e poi stavo
consultando il mio libro storie paurose
a scuola dei misteri Perché ha tante
informazioni sulle creature tra cui i
lupi mannari voi ce l'avete Scrivetemi
nei commenti se voi ce l'avete l'avete
già letto ma presto vediamo lo sapevo
questa è un'informazione importantissima
sui lupi mannari e infatti mi basta
prendere una
cosa Perfetto ora inizia la trappola per
la lupa andiamo
Ehi Lupa
Vanara sono io Cappuccetto Rosso e sono
venuta qua per dirti che sei brutta e
pelosa
cosina e ha i denti gialli Sì ha i denti
gialli
bruttissimi quindi Vitale non ti vorrà
mai perché Vitale ama me soltanto me non
te
Capito Aiutami Sì Vitale non ti vorrà
mai perché Vitale ama
me Eh
sì ah ah forza
Forse sei brutta Vitale non ti vorrà
mai non tirà
mai
beccati
[Musica]
questa prova a prendermi
Lupa
[Musica]
Preto Dai vieni verso Qua si sta
avvicinando la mia trappola sta
funzionando sono qua Lupa sono qua vieni
pure a
prendermi
Sì è in trappola è in trappola La mia
trappola ha funzionato ora che la lupa è
in trappola posso andare a liberare
Vitale Ciao ciao Lupa Ciao
ciao Vitale Vitale Sono arrivata a
liberarti che cosa vuoi non mi vedi che
ormai sono lupo
mannaro Oh no la trasformazione è già
iniziata aspetta aspetta aspetta
ascoltami
ascoltami ed è stata tutta colpa della
lupa Mannara e che la lupa Mannara che
ti ha trasformato Cappuccetto Rosso è
caduto nella Tala del lupo ma che stai
dicendo non sono Cappuccetto Rosso non
lo vedi sono Anita mi sono travestite da
Cappuccetto Rosso per stendere una
trappola alla Lupa e ci sono anche
riuscita ho intrappolato la lupa la f
hai intrappolato la lupa là fuori Perché
che cosa vuoi fare Mi è venuta un'idea
visto che hai menzionato la lupa adesso
verrai qui con me Ti metterò in cella
Ehi come ti permetti Lasciami stare ti
attento Tu sei vitale non sei un lupo
manato Lasciami stare e io non sono
Cappuccetto Rosso sono ner cerca di
ricordarsi adesso ti ricordo io una cosa
ti metterò in cella e quando tornerà
alla Lupa ti mangeremo
Sarà un bellissimo
banchetto non credo proprio perché tu
tornerai normale adesso capito Torna
subito normale non sei un lupo Sì sì
certo certo Funziona proprio così vieni
qua in cella vieni in
cella ma Vitale non sei un lupo sei
vitale Ricordati dei biscotti delle
torte della pasta al sugo e dei ravioli
Insomma tutte le cose che ti piacciono
da mangiare la
pizza trasformazione proprio completata
se Vitale non torna in se pensando al
cibo allora è veramente completata la
trasformazione non mi resta che passare
al mio piano segreto Ehi quale piano
segreto non ti permettere a mettere i
bastoni tra le ruote tra me e la lupa
Hai capito E perché sentiamo Che cosa
succede se mi metto i bastoni fra le
ruote succede che ti mangeremo ancor
prima e ti sgranocchi Remo
tutta Ehi ma che mangiare me Tu devi
tornare visale devi tornare a mangiare
biscotti non me sì sì ma quale biscotti
prepareremo un bel banchetto e ti
mangeremo e poi scapperemo insieme Sì
con la lupa scapperò e andremo a vivere
nella foresta Ma che stai
dicendo Sì uler Remo alla
luna Ma come Ma tu sei fidanzato con me
non ti ricordi che stai incendo scappare
con la lupa Sì ha conquistato il mio mio
cuore vedi mi ha trasformato in un lupo
proprio come lei basta non voglio più
parlare con te dopo che hai detto questa
cosa
Addio mi ha detto che la lupa era
intrappolata là fuori devo andare a
liberarla ha bisogno di me
adesso è arrivato il momento di agire
sul mio piano ho preso queste cose di
costo E con questi trucchi io creerò il
rossetto d'argento e sapete che
l'argento è il nemico numero uno dei
lupi mannari e dopo vedrete cosa
succederà ma prima devo mettere il
rossetto Lupa Lupa dove sei Sono io il
tuo
tesoro
lupa Dove sei andata sento il tuo odore
qui Lupa Vieni Esci fuori sono venuto a
salvarti Dai che ci aspetta un bel
banchetto Ehi ma era proprio qui sento
il suo
odore sarà qui intorno o forse è già
entrata in casa ma Ehi non può mica
iniziare a mangiare senza di me
devo
raggiungerla si
mangiaa Ehi Vitale Sì devo dirti una
cosa Che cosa devo dirti una cosa
all'orecchio all'orecchio e sentiamo
allora è un segreto quindi devi
avvicinarti di più ok mi avvicino di
[Musica]
più ma non sento
niente ma ma ma cos'è Cosa hai fatto è
il rossetto
d'argento e l'argento è l'arma numero
uno contro i lupi mannari quindi tra
poco tornerai normale tornerai Vitale
tornerai il mio fidanzato che cosa hai
fatto Ma come non vuoi tornare normale
Io sono un lupo non sono più vitale Ah
questa cosa brucia che cosa mi hai fatto
sta funzionando sta
funzionando cosa sta succedendo Dai dai
dai sfati sfati sfati argento sfati a
funzionare sei tornato normale ma mi
riconosci adesso non sono Cappuccetto
Rosso sono Anita mi hai riconosciuto
Certo che ti riconosco sei Anita è
vestita da Cappuccetto Rosso però sì ti
riconosco bene allora Liberami subito
prima che torni la Rupa e che ci fai
chiusa là dentro Certo che ti libero dai
mi hai riuso tu io ti ho
rinchiuso Oh no la
[Musica]
lupa sei rimasta male che che tu hai
baciato me soprattutto che sei tornato
normale non sei più
lupo eh lupa Mi dispiace però è la mia
fidanzata tu mi hai trasformato
eh Dai poverino vieni tieniti qua mi
dispiace magari troverai un lupo per
lupò mandare ho dato a te sai troverai
quello giusto per te
[Applauso]
Vedrai Poverina adesso mi fa Bena adesso
che non ha quella
assassino mi fa un po' pena Dai magari
ti aiutiamo noi a trovare un
fidanzato Oh no Poverina cosa facciamo E
dai Lupa ho io un'idea E che ne pensi se
magari ogni tanto ti inviteremo a casa
Eh che cosa ne pensi così potrai venire
a trovarci Passeremo un po' di tempo
insieme e così avrai due nuovi amici No
Vitale Ma che stai dicendo non possiamo
dare un vero lupo manaro così grosso a
casa nostra adesso la vedi tutta
tranquilla dolce e triste ma magari le
tornerà quel suo istinto assassino E dai
poverina mi fa pena Dai vieni qua ti do
l'ultimo
abbraccio mi stai stritolando mi stai
stritolando Lupa
Lupa Ok piano piano manteniamo le
distanza Eh brava sì sì avrai due nuovi
amici non un fidanzato due nuovi amici
due due eh no no noi due Noi due dai dai
dai dai potrai venire a trovarci Quando
vorrai facciamo passare un po' di mesi
traa tra una tra una visita e l'altra
Vabbè vabbè giorni giorni facciamo
passare un po' di
giorni sì dai va bene una volta ci
potrai tornare a trovare una una volta
ok solo una volta Ehi ma voi cliccate mi
piace se volete che la lupa torni a
trovarci un'altra volta cliccate mi
piace qua sotto ehm quindi dai ci
vediamo un'altra volta Ciao ci vediamo
[Musica]
Ciao
ciao ciao
ciao ciao ciao ciao
ciao e ciao
ciao ciao Vai via
insomma non se ne voleva più andare Beh
abbiamo scappato anche
questa Oh che
dormita Buongiorno
Anita
Buongiorno
[Musica]
Meno male è stato solo un brutto
sogno vediamo dove devo
andare
Wow aito aito aito aito mi senti chi c'è
eh La Lupa la lupa è ancora qui l'ho
trovata in bagno sono entrato in bagno
questa mattina e lei stava lì davanti
allo specchio con con il mio spazzolino
si stavo lavando i denti Ah ma che stai
dicendo è andato via la lupa Mannara No
no Mi devi credere stavo in bagno Vai a
controllare senti fammi finire questa
partita adesso ma come finire la partita
Ti sto dicendo che c'è la lupa lì Uffa
mi hai fatto sfracellare di nuovo Non
c'è nessuna Lupa e vaii a controllare
Vedilo coi tuoi occhi vediamo Guarda
vedi era proprio qua Cioè era qua ecco
te l'ho detto non c'è nessuno ma no
stavo Vedi c'è il mio il mio dentifricio
qua stavo utilizzando il mio spazzolino
ma non c'è nessuno guarda ci sei solo tu
forse ti sei visto tu allo specchio e ti
sei spaventato ma non ti dico che c'era
la lupa forse non ti sei ancora
svegliato da stamattina Io torno a
finire la mia partita Ciao Forse aveva
ragione Anita magari era solo un brutto
sogno Certo però era così realistico
Magari la prossima volta provo a darmi
un pizzicotto e magari mi sveglio vado
ad innaffiare i fiori
[Musica]
adesso dei fiori Grazie Eh ma ma quindi
non è un sogno aspetta aspetta aspetta
Questa volta mi sono ricordato prima mi
do un pizzicotto per vedere se sto
sognando Ahia ciaoo sono l'emoji di
Anita Sbaglio o ancora non hai cliccato
mi piace Mi raccomando Clicca subito mi
piace sotto a questo video e se non hai
ancora il mio nuovo libro La città
stregata agli investigatori del mistero
Clicca nel link in descrizione Per
ordinarlo subito e lo troverai in
libreria dal 17 ottobre Prendilo anche
tu per entrare a far parte del nostro
team di investigatori e risolveremo un
sacco di misteri assieme
Ahia
Ahia mi ha spostato la
mandibola Ma quindi non sto sognando ma
ma ma ma che ci fai ancora qui perché mi
hai dato questi fiori che cosa
vuoi
eh Ha detto che mi ha dato questi fiori
perché mi
ama
no Lupa Dai lasciami in pace lasciami in
pace no no no no no no no
non
[Musica]
nuovo grazie Beh hai scelto i fiori meno
belli del giardino Però grazie lo stesso
eh prego prego Ah in realtà è stata la
lupa a darmi i
fiori Sì l'ho trovata qua fuori Mi sono
anche dato un pizzicotto per vedere se
se sono sveglio oppure no ma in realtà
lei è qua fuori Mi ha inseguito mi ha
stolto la mbola mi voleva abbracciare si
fa Cocchiere ma per questo che sono
scappato me li ha dati lei i fiori
Ancora con questa storia della Lupa non
c'è nessuno te lo stai immaginando e no
Lei era proprio qua fuori Guarda Andiamo
a vedere vediamo se c'è davvero questa
Lupa attenta
però vediamo un po' Sì sì era proprio
qua lei era qui mi ha dato i fiori e poi
io sono scappato da questa parte io ho
paura però Aiutami eh aut io qua vedo
solo un annaffiatoio Eh sì stavo
annaffiando i fiori i fiori
Eh non c'è traccia di Lupa Eh guarda
Magari è andata qui da qualche parte si
è nascosta e Aiutami però eh Ma no non
c'è nessuno tu sei rimasto troppo
scioccato dalla scorsa volta Avete visto
gli scorsi episodi in cui la lupa ha
sbaciucchi Vitale se non li avete visti
andati a vederli dopo questo video e
quindi dopo che sono successe quelle
cose Tu ora la immagini ovunque ti
sembra di vederla dappertutto ma in
realtà se n'è andata via sì sì proprio
così io la vedo dappertutto ma perché
lei c'è davvero non ti preoccupare Non
c'è nessuna lupo è solo la tua testolina
ma questo tu lo dici perché non hai mai
baciato una Lupa non hai mai sentito il
suo alito di ferro di ferro Sì ferro e
zolfo tipo Beh per fortuna non mi è mai
capitato Comunque io ora devo continuare
la mia partita Ciao ma come Anita
continua a non credermi devo riuscire a
convincerla in qualche modo
Uffa Ma perché Anita non mi crede dovrei
trovare qualche indizio per farle capire
che la lupa è stata qua vediamo se
magari ha lasciato qualche pelo qui per
terra non sembra
esserci che che cosa ci fai tu
qui No no basta basta basta
[Musica]
basta Aspetta aspetta Facciamo così
facciamo così io me ne vado e poi tu
puoi fare quello che vuoi Ok vado a
chiamare cosa
vuoi che cosa Che cosa c'hai nascosto là
dietro
tu cuore tu cuore io tu cuore io tu
cuore
io tu
tu tu oh C'hai una mano che ti
sboccia cosa stai
facendo Che
cos'è Non mi sembra una scatola di
biscotti devo avere paura non devo avere
paura Io sto già avendo un sacco di
paura No guarda io accetto solo scatole
di biscotti il regalo e questo che cos'è
cioccolatini per caso ah
se Apre questa esplode No io voglio che
esploda
niente
Lupa La devo aprire io La devo aprire io
ok L'ho
presa devo
aprirlo
maell ma è di
cioccolato Pens magari si
[Musica]
scartare Lupa Ma che cosa stai
dicendo
sposarmi come Sì aspetta aspetta Lupa
Lupa No no aspetta devi capire una cosa
Io amo
Anita non posso la mia
fidanzata il mio cuore batte per
lei calmati però Lupa calmati non T
arrabbiare no con te non posso e il mio
cuore
diita vedi Lupa io non potrò mai amarti
il mio cuore falte per la
[Musica]
vita oh no si è arrabbiata tantissimo
questa volta le ho proprio spezzato il
cuore ma non posso sposarmi con la lupa
Eh devo andare ad avvisare Anita adesso
e ora credo proprio che mi creda visto
che ho l'anello prima di tornare a
giocare vado a prendere un albicocca Ehi
Ma voi avete lasciato un mi piace Mi
raccomando cliccate un mi piace qua
sotto e se volete entrare a far parte
del nostro team iscrivetevi e attivate
la campanella e ora andiamo a prendere
una buonissima
[Musica]
albicocca Eccolo qua il mio albero di
Albicocco devo prendere l'alb più grande
che sarà più dolce Magari questa vabbè
no mi è
caduta Vabbè questa andrà
[Musica]
bene era
buona
Ok prossimo
[Musica]
stage Vitale mi hai
chiamato Chissà dov'è finito Vitale ma
ora devo finire questo
livello
Vitale che stai facendo
Ah ho
capito Vuoi farmi una
sorpresa eh hai mal di gola Forse parli
in modo un po'
strano Ok ma dimmi che cos'è questa
sorpresa mi hai mi hai comprato un
regalo qualcosa Oh che bello Non vedo
l'ora di vedere cosa mi hai comprato che
sfa farà c'è una torta magari ok Devo
seguirti quindi va
[Musica]
bene ok Ti seguo Stiamo andando fuori
forse
ok
eh
eh ma è sicuro che non è uno scherzo
no ok
sentiamo c'è una torta con la panna
magari per me eh Eh ma allora dove mi
hai portato come ho posso togliere la
benda
eh posso
toglierla Mi vuoi
[Musica]
[Risate]
sposare Eh ma è sicuro che non è uno
scherzo
no m Ok
vediamo C'è una torta con la panna
magari per me eh eh Ma allora dove mi
hai portato come ho posso togliere la
benda
eh posso
[Musica]
toglierla Non era una
sorpresa mi hai portato in prigione
nuovamente Ma perché Che cosa vuoi da
me
[Musica]
tu tu
Amello tu vuoi Vitale
vero e che no non ce l'avrai mai Vitale
perché Vitale am me te l'ho già detto
non avrai mai Vitale Vitale è solo
mio è
così
No no io non me ne vado Mi dispiace io
non me ne andrò e quindi siccome non me
ne andrò mai Vitale è solo
mio
[Musica]
ho capito la lupa vuole mangiarmi perché
se mi mangerà io non ci sarò più vitale
sarà costretto a
sposarla No no Mi dispiace puoi
fantasticare quanto vuoi Ma questo non
succederà
[Risate]
mai
anche se io sono in prigione anche se mi
mangerai Vitale non si sposterà mai a
non immaginart Tea proprio una vita con
[Musica]
Vitale
Ehi ma invece di
fantasticare in tutto questo tempo Dov'è
finito Vitale non lo vedo da un sacco tu
sai
dov'è
ma no non sai dov'è se tu non sai dov'è
e neanche io so dov'è Dov'è
Vitale sì Io rimango qua Tanto sono in
prigione ah Ok faccio
sza
Ok
benissimo sono riuscita a far
allontanare la lupa così proverò a
evadere da questa prigione
adesso ma mi sono nascosto benissimo la
lupa ancora non mi ha trovato qui ma che
Che fine ha fatto Anita dove sarà
finita Ah e tu che ci fai qua Stai
cercando
Vitale Guarda l'ho visto da quella parte
sì e poi dopo scappavo di corsa di là di
là guarda
là Oh no Devo trovare il modo di
riuscire a uscire da questa prigione Ehi
aspetta prima la lupa ha sbattuto qua e
ha fatto cadere due sbarre della
prigione non le ha posizionate bene Oh
ce l'ho
fatta Sì sono uscita dalla prigione Ora
non mi resta che cercare Vitale presto
andiamo Ah ancora tu che cosa c'è questa
volta io e tu Croce X per no Ok scusa Ah
sto zitto sto zitto ok
io e te
[Musica]
con facciamo il karaoke sì facciamo il
karaoke La volta è bello e divertente
Cantiamo
Insieme aspetta Ma dov'è finita Anita
non è che le hai fatto
qualcosa che cosa sono questi
mugli non hai fatto
niente più o meno che cosa intendi con
più
meno se io se io
vedere Anita se io voglio vedere
Anita se io voglio vedere Anita
Sì io e
[Musica]
te dobbiamo ballare E
baciarci Non ti arrabbiare però penso di
aver capito che cosa intende però non lo
voglio fare Quindi se riproviamo se io e
te voglio se io se io voglio vedere
Alina io e te ci
dobbiamo non è abbracciare non
è Allora se io voglio rivedere Anita io
e te ci dobbiamo sposare
no non voglio ma è l'unico modo per
vedere Anita
però E quindi che cosa dobbiamo fare
Dobbiamo sposarci Eh ce l'hai me l'hai
dato prima l'anello Come
no mi devo inginocchiare e fare la
proposta a
[Musica]
te sto piangendo prima ancora di fare la
proposta
devo dire Devo dire che cosa va bene
Lupa mi vuoi
sposare Sì ha detto Sì che bello come
sono
felice Vitale ha fatto la proposta di
matrimonio alla Lupa e ha anche
accettato aspetta Ho un
piano ma visto che ti ho fatto la
proposta ti ho dato l'anello e tutto
quanto Adesso mi fai vedere Anita per
favore come no ma ma come no mi hai
detto che proposto matrimonio se voglio
vedere Anita zitto
Ok se voglio rivedere Anita Sì io
te ho capito Dobbiamo celebrare il
matrimonio adesso hai organizzato tutto
lo sapevo
[Musica]
guarda ma quindi adesso che cosa
dobbiamo
[Musica]
fare Ah dobbiamo aspettare quello che ci
sposa ma io in realtà mi aspettavo il
mio matrimonio con Anita non con
te Guarda che cosa mi tocca fare pur di
rivedere
Anita
[Musica]
sono venuto qua per celebrare il
matrimonio di Vitale e Lupa
giusto perfetto iniziamo
subito Benissimo siamo qui riuniti a
celebrare il matrimonio del signor
Vitale con la
signora
[Musica]
Lupa Allora iniziamo subito vuoi tu
prendere signor Vitale come tua
legittima sposa la signora
Lupa mi sa che non ho molta molta
scelta sì per rivedere Anita
Sì vuoi tu Lupa prendere come tuo
legittimo sposo il signor Vitale finché
morte non vi
separi Ma sei
sicura benissimo potete ora scambiarvi
gli
[Musica]
anelli
[Risate]
Ok può baciare la sposa ma siamo sicuri
Bisogna proprio farlo
[Musica]
Sì sì sei sempre tu sì sì Ma possiamo
possiamo farlo dopo il bacio magari no
Per ufficializzare devi baciare la sposa
ok ok
ok E ora Per ufficializzare questo
matrimonio non deve esserci nessuna
opposizione c'è qualcuno che si oppone a
questo
matrimonio Io mi oppongo
io
io io sono Sono Anita non mi riconosci
Sì questo matrimonio è annullato Mi
dispiace per te Lupa non ti sposerai
capitale tantissimo aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta avevo già pensato a un
piano sta per arrivare il testimone di
nozze testimone di not Eccolo eccolo
Eccolo eccolo Ciao ragazzi eh Ma cosa
sta succedendo Qui sì lex Sì sì Ti
ricordi che ti eri innamorato anche di
lui perché è un bellissimo lupo Eccolo
qua Eccolo quell qua ma mi avevate
invitato al vostro matrimonio perché c'è
quel lupo che schifo perché c'è quel
lupo lì Ma perché è vestita da sposa che
schifo e tu sei pensavi di essere il
testimone ma in realtà sei il nuovo
sposa il nuovo sposo della lupa Ma chi
io con chi Con lei sì oh mi avete
incastrato un'altra volta un'altra
trappola Che
schifo Sì sì Ric corril
pure